welcome back to New Rockstar I'm Jessica
Clemens filling in for Eric Voss while
he's out on paternity leave and some
recent set photos from Deadpool 3 have
us wondering if the MCU version of the
Fantastic 4 could be making their debut
in the upcoming Deadpool film oo and of
course a big old spoiler warning for
everything we talk about today in case
any of it comes true cuz y'all know I'm
Miss Cleo an impostor also yes we're
going over those set photos I have
nothing but love for my king I'm just
relaying the news it's my job don't be
upset with me Mr Blake Lively I'll call
them pool Scoops I'll do whatever you
want just don't be mad at me and before
we dive into it be sure to check out
nerd r. shop to get the latest and
greatest and new rock stars merch and if
you're looking to get something special
for the nerd in your life this holiday
season be sure to order before December
11th to receive your items before
Christmas grabbing some merch From Nerd
r. shop is a great way to support the
channel and all the awesome work we do
I'm also wearing it right now isn't it
cute this right here you can get it in
different colors and it's perfect long
sleeves I love them okay into the video
Ryan Reynolds recently posted his
opinions of the leak set photos that
have been taken and released widely on
the internet he mentions using real
natural environments using practical
effects opposed to being indoors it's
not a surprise people have already been
able to spoil some of the surprises
already since they're shooting those
bits Outdoors he hopes social channels
and websites will hold back on showing
these images before they're ready to
which I say again this video contains
spoilers leak set photos most we've seen
before I'm just doing my job I'm
relaying what I know I'm relaying the
news and I still respect and love Ryan
Reynolds dearly he even knows big Disney
is watching and paying for all of this
and I love that he made fun of quby like
he did like like right here such a
really weird Niche I don't think people
actually know what the quibby logo even
looks like but also I love all of those
leaked photoshopped ones that he
actually posted on Twitter and I wish
the Predator would show up in Deadpool 3
one of the biggest announcements fans
anticipate from Marvel is the cast for
the upcoming Fantastic 4 film currently
slated to be released May 2nd 2025 Matt
shakman is directing the film The
Original writers for the film are Jeff
Kaplan and Ian Springer but in March
2023 Josh Freedman was brought in to do
rewrites on the script all of this was
before the writers and actors struck
over the summer and fall so we're still
waiting waiting to see if any additional
changes have been made to the production
team the film is scheduled to start
shooting next month in January for my
birthday it's like a little gift for me
but what does all of this have to do
with Deadpool 3 I'm glad you asked and
this is where we'll be getting into some
of those leaked set photos so if you
don't want to see those photos turn away
now this is like my third time warning
you some Deadpool 3 set photos appeared
online this week that showed some
interesting Vehicles being driven around
Mad Max style one of these vehicles
really caught our attention it's this
little guy right here this weird vehicle
has a unique design but most notably at
the very front there appears to be a
four between the headlights regardless
who do we know that loves the number
four the Fantastic Four of course and
Marvel's first family loves to travel in
style often seen using the Fantastic car
there have been many iterations of the
Fantastic car over the years but most
designs have the feature of being able
to split into four separate vehicles the
image taken from the set could be one of
those vehicles and its retrofuturistic
design means it could be straight from
the 60s version of the Fantastic 4 they
may even edit out the wheels and post
and have the ship hovering around like
Luke Skywalker's land speeder we don't
know when in time them Ed Fantastic 4
film will be set there were rumors last
year that the film could be set in the
1960s maybe that's the case for this
film or maybe that rumor was tied to
what we will see in Deadpool 3 now this
sequence could be set in a place like
the void there has been speculation that
Deadpool 3 will have connection to the
TVA with Matthew mcfaden joining the
cast in his role rumored to be tied to
the TVA and Wade Wilson's time hopping
Antics at the end of Deadpool 2 would
have certainly grabbed the attention of
the TVA if it is the void then that
could mean it's just a prune fantastic
car and we'll never see the Fantastic 4
or it could be a situation where we see
yet another multi ival version of the
Fantastic 4 similar to how John krisy
jumped into the role of 838 Reed
Richards for Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness but that's no fun
instead what if this is Marvel's way of
introducing the official cast Marvel has
made Moves Like This Before introducing
Black Panther and Spider-Man in Captain
America Civil War before their solo
films you wouldn't start your car
without gas in the tank and I will not
start my brain without coffee in my
belly it's non-negotiable and I'll be
honest my old system of just trusting a
pod to get it right was never great
whether I'm at home or on the road I
need coffee and I needed to be good good
Arrow Press good Aro press is like a
French press but better it combines the
best of several Brew methods for a
completely unique and delicious flavor
profile smooth rich and full body no
bitterness no grit and it's portable so
once you get your arrow press it can
come with you everywhere from San
Francisco to Burbank to San Francisco to
Burbank you get the idea it's compact
durable and single-handedly responsible
for saving me from Bad Hotel coffee just
add grounds pour in hot water stir for 5
seconds Brew for 30 seconds and then
press into a mug and you're good to go
in less than 2 minutes you've got a
perfect cup of coffee and a clean Aero
press it's great Aeropress is the best
reviewed coffee press on the planet with
more than 55,000 f-star reviews so if
you're looking for a good stocking
stuffer for your crew's coffee
connoisseur look no further Aeropress is
shockingly Affordable less than 50 bucks
and we've got an incredible offer for
our audience visit Aero press.com neww
rockstars that's AE r o p r ss.com neww
rockstars to save up to 20% it's time to
ditch the drive-thru Toss The French
Press and say yes to better mornings
fueled by better coffee Aeropress ships
to the USA in over 60 countries around
the world and we thank Aeropress for
sponsoring this video If Fantastic 4
goes into production next month there's
still plenty of time to squeeze them
into Deadpool 3 which is coming to
theaters July 26 2024 it's Marvel's only
scheduled theatrical release for 2024
and if that remains the case why not
make it huge with the inclusion of
Marvel's first family perhaps it's even
the Fantastic Four who saved Deadpool
and properly bring him into 616 or maybe
it's the other way around and it's the
Fantastic Four who are stuck in the void
and Deadpool is the one who saves them
that could be the explanation as to why
the Fantastic 4 have not appeared in the
MCU up until this point he who remains
could have proven the Fantastic 4 as
part of his manufactur sacred timeline
banishing them from 616 as we know or
maybe one of Reed Richard's experiments
went arai and instead of winding up
somewhere like the Negative Zone they
found themselves trapped in the void
we'll have to wait until Deadpool 3
drops to find out for sure but so many
theories could be made here let me know
what you guys think in the comments we
found some other very interesting things
in these set photos this beautiful car
that looks like it was modified to look
like a horrible death machine from Mad
Max but this car must be the Ford
flathead 32 Roadster that Tony Stark
owned and worked on in the first Iron
Man movie and the last left in his
original collection of cars we see in
Iron Man 2 they are identical but the
bottom like ridges and double back tires
resemble red skull's 1942 V16 Coupe
there's a possibility that if this is
the void the people use leftover car
parts red schools and Tony to make this
machine so red school and Tony stuff
might have ended up in the void for some
reason the vehicle itself has a gun that
resembles the Hydra Cannon so this baby
is also prepared to kill it also has
this gnarly looking cannon on the side
that could be a repurpose Hydro weapon
the more I look at all of this it feels
like this scene has to be a parody of
Mad Max meets furiosa meets Dune furiosa
and dune 2 will have been out for at
least two months when Deadpool 3 drops
we know everyone's pumped for it
Deadpool loves these kind of jokes too
he's made fun of himself in the post
credit scenes for Deadpool 2 so watch
more funny references like that make
their way through maybe Ryan auditioned
for Mad Max and didn't get in and so
he's making fun of it who really knows
another image we saw was the cupcake van
from moonight it's certainly spliced
with something I just don't know what it
is it feels like compared to the other
cars this is their version of the war
rig but like the Tony Stark and Red
Skull car it's so interesting to make
this the vehicle that makes its way into
Deadpool 3 and it's not like ant-man's
van from endgame that would be literally
insane if it was if this is the void
Moon Knight's ice cream truck was pruned
but if this is a post-apocalyptic
Universe it's cool to see that moonight
or at least Arthur Harrow's goons have
somewhat left an impression there are a
ton of other images that were released
of other characters that we've spoken
about in other videos other smaller
vehicles and background actors but these
images stood out for us and we wanted to
talk about them and their implications
or is the reasoning behind them being in
Deadpool 3 to begin with my fingers are
crossed on this being a quick Mad Max
inspired scene but could you imagine if
the Fantastic 4 were introduced here
that would be it would be Madness it
would create nothing but chaos and
that's it for my little video on the
Fantastic 4 entering the MCU via
Deadpool 3 and all the surprises we can
expect I love you Ryan Reynolds Ryan
Reynolds I really love you I love
Deadpool please don't be mad at me for
sharing all these images follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu Clemens
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
see you on the other
[Music]
side